today I'm going to show you how to set
up a professional PHP environment in the
cloud using zend server with Google
Cloud launcher after starting the cloud
launch or home page click infrastructure
then click then server next click launch
on compute engine select an existing
project or create a new one for your
xenserver instance for this example I'll
pick an existing project then click
continue after the page loads you can
configure your new instance give the
instance a name and deployment zone you
can also configure additional details
that apply to your project when you're
finished click the deploy button at the
bottom once it is loaded you'll see all
the details you need to get started with
your xenserver instance note the
username and password and click Launch
that brings up the xenserver login page
type your username and password and
click login that's all there is to it to
get started with the xenserver on cloud
launcher click on the link in the
comments and thanks for watching